الى القاهره نذهب وينضم الينا من هناك
والد الطفل المتغيب عثروا
عليه الوالد محمد الشامي استاذ محمد الحمد
لله على سلامه ابنك وبالتالي سؤال الابز
كيف حدث ذلك ايه اللي حصل ازاي مين الراجل
ده
الراجل ده ما اعرفهوش هو جه قدام البيت
لعب مع الاطفال بتاعه الشارع قدام باب
وبعد كده
خد الواد على اساس ان هو يعمل له ايميل
ببجي
وصاحبه لحد الشارع وبعد كده ما بانش ثاني
بقى كاميرات ايه اللي جابته تابعنا
الكمرات وزاره الداخليه تابعت الكمرات
وجابته بعد 4 ايام
طيب الحمد لله طبعا على سلامته يعني سلامه
ابنك استاذ محمد وعلى انه رجع يعني الحمد
لله كله صحته تمام وكل شيء تمام محمد قديش
يعني ما بعرف بهذا الزمن اللي احنا فيه
هل تعتقد بانه في مسؤوليه نوعا ما على
الاهل بانهم على الاقل يتحدثوا مع اولادهم
يفهموا الاولاد انه مش المفروض تتحدثوا مع
اي شخص غريب واكيد مش المفروض انكم تذهبوا
مع اي شخص غريب حتى لو قال لكم راح اعطيكم
حلويات او اعملكم اي
حساب على لعبتكم المفضله هل كان في لك
حديث مع ابنك بهذا الاطار قبل هذه الحادثه
اه انا كنت كل يوم بقول له الكلام ده كنت
كل يوم بقول له ما تمشيش مع حد ما تاخذش
حاجه من حد وبرضه الاهالي برده كان
المفروض تعمل كده
ولكن على ما يبدو براءه الاطفال بتخليهم
انه يصدقوا اي شخص بيجي بقول لهم
بدي اعمل بدي اخذكم على مكان جميل او او
اعطيكم حلويات وممكن انهم يذهبوا معه
هو المفروض اي طفل ما يمشيش ولا اي حد
واحمد ابني مشي مش وراه على اساس اللي هو
هيجيب له ايميل ببجي ومش ايميل ببجي وضحك
عليه طبعا وخدوه وقعد اربع ايام
وجبناها من القليوب الحمد لله طيب يعني
ايه ازاي فقدتوه يعني بعد اربع ايام حتى
عاد
ما هي ما هي ظروف عمليه الاختطاف قالوا
لكم ايه الداخليه
قالوا لنا اللي احنا هندور على الواد
وهنجيبه ان شاء الله مش هنكمل يومين ان
شاء الله وهنجيبه وقعدوا طبعا يراجع في
ابو زعبل وفي الخانكه وفي جميع جميع
الخطوات
قال ايه في اعترافاته قال ايه المتهم
اللي خطف
المهتم طبعا
يعني معترف اللي هو خاطف الولد ومش بس انا
بطلب بطلب اللي هو ياخذ اعدام عشان ما
يعملهاش ما حدش يعملها تاني
طيب
يعني لاحظت الحمد لله انه يعني ابنك بصحه
جيده جنبك هل تحدثت انت وياه الولد هل
اعطاك يعني قال اي قصص حوله كيف وين وين
اخذوا كيف قضى هذول الايام هل كان يطعميه
مثلا ام لا
هو طبعا يعني هو قعد به ليلتين في على
محطه قليوب طبعا الواد كان متبهدل برضو من
قله الاكل والكلام ده بس الحمد لله رجع لي
بالسلامه يعني
لازم اسالك نفسيه احمد عامله ايه اتغير
ازاي بعد الاربعه ايام دي
هو الصراحه يعني هو انا بحاول انا اسيه
الموقف ده خالص هو مستوعب الحاجه دي اتخطف
اربعه ايام
مستوعب بس يعني انا بحاول انسيه يعني
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات